and thank you pushing this in addition
to speak with you butters you could host
an affair before every I just want to
apologize for my bad english I hope to
be under step ahead and fly into 10
involving we proved recently that is a
good tip of that people to have silent
movie you don't have yet silent
conferences about this source Califia
you know this other senators can of
there we are in fact three different
offense the one you everybody knows here
is the affair with every second general
in monata and as far as you are all
supposed to know everything about that I
will not
we just works more to others the second
began when a full time came back after
the dismissal of the charges came back
to front it is a twisting balloon affair
the fresh young writer who claimed that
the partition try to break up the other
group edge of the group in during an
interview schmid of info book the mother
her mother is a responsible of the
social spotter and she can feel that she
hadn't informed by mr. memo immediately
after the fact that what happened but
she and yes waiting
not too much any companies thinking at
that time that the personal cost focused
on would be iron down the more benefit
the Shikoku when offers made the
allegation public on televisions on
French television in 2007 but only
brought their to magistrate last tonight
just when the Soviet an affair who was
about to collapse in October the french
prosecutors organized earth first to
pass confrontation between twist and
bynum and saw scale and after that they
declare that they are prima facie
evidence that the sexual assault took
place but the case was too old to
prosecute so they thought
in fresh no sexual assault as the
shorter status of limitation three years
why was an attempted way when you have
tended under French rule we stand by la
would still have taken a complaint
directly to judges and the money there
they review the evidence but she decided
by the way not to do that and she said
quite clearly in the letter that the
prosecutor sent me she says he says that
there was a sexual assault so my status
as lifting is at least recognize how
come
the self case the self affair in the
affair is the caltrain affair from the
name of a four star hotel in the
northern city of Manila where the
prostitution ring was discovered missing
the name of sauce God appeared in an
investigation which began at one year
ago but was published but by the French
newspaper only in last October source
and was accused of an integral part in
activities related to prostitution in
different cities directing France in
Belgium in Spain and is here in
Washington and just two days before the
cfl in the email and in all this
business man Oh
in 2010 and 2000 indeed a lawyer for
Sasuke can still recently and attended
rivers but say this client would not
have been aware if the woman were
prostitute so stan is now scheduled to
appear before judge in the March twenty
and twenty days and people eating from
you know that prostitution is not
illegal it is set in the newspapers that
Sasuke will probably be charged of
complicity of an authentic of
probability obesity do
consoling this is to temper
go visit your
then misuse of corporate assets was set
that we do justice to even it is proved
that you knew that these 40 is where
failed both companies with such an
accumulation of affairs in the other it
is easy to understand that the social
situation in france is now completely
different and far worse than it was not
only 10 months ago before I was arrested
but even six months ago when he came
back france at the beginning of the
double at that time he boat to in built
his reputation and given is before it
was too late for the IMF of today for
any role in the flesh
babe you know the man Bridget to a
new departure trying to take some
advantage of the dismissal of the
charges and this did not happen the
cotton case has had an enormous impact
not only on earth roskill reputation but
also on the attitude of French people
towards human and towards to sue scott
affair as a ward after the time of
sideration the type of super tations
came the time for separate first people
did not accept any way to be implied in
any way in another scandal in fact as
commodities don't speak to me about this
guy anymore is since November the center
should we are the most as far as he is
concerned so at the time
the situation falls was countries glad
in many ways and East future is very
dark the media showed us an amount of
disrespect proportional to the bus
respect for a very important man and the
most growing expression of this
disrespect is you can image how many
ruffles sketches lessons imitations as
interest you have in any any part of the
country use as a way for pushing down
the man who was was both it's not the
system st. I don't make this short
summary is very simplified form
story but it's enough for me to
introduce what in my opinion is the very
difficulty of this affair it is not only
criminal dis dis I can't descriptive
cases gazed on well question is what
happened during the famous nine minutes
when deficit yellow and Sasuke whoever
long in the 20-26 street is low in size
of the day this nine minutes whatever
will be said about that in the future we
have now seen process positive
this night minutes are over india baat
or another story the one of the form of
a man frozen top to the bottom in this
port as Tuscan appear to be quite
different in his life that the man the
people thought he was and when I say
that I don't know I'm not thinking about
the ordinary French people but even I am
thinking about this very special persons
walking them to buy this little world of
politicians journalists etc who this
so-called elite used to share a certain
science about tsk behaviors towards
women inception consistent without XIV
notice that all this affair offers CC CC
instruction as you say box as
but when we thought that by typical Cena
the most at the center of a program
concentration was operational questions
not only for the protagonist but for
society we promptly discovered that bi
that scene where another in the less
bright light and that the real point was
in his other seam between the trouble
between the two teams I will people of
death this double sink approach for
three questions which I think are the
most astute ated among such people as
far as gender issues are concerned the
question of presumption of innocence for
the defendant the question of resolution
of veracity
for for the
convenient and the question of the
rapport between seduction and consent in
French culture and things first the
perturbation of the presumption of
innocence during the first week after
sauce can was arrested it is difficult
from ear to imagine the the degree of
incredulity emotion simulation among
friendly we could not believe our earth
for our peers rapport seems to be like
the nightmare and a scene concentrating
or displeased and was able to turn them
in a white indignation and put the
station against America it was the veldt
perfil to perform on earth to earth of
rain per person
that's the first syllable of perpetrate
isn't your belt Wallace organized as
remember he made 54 French people this
report was not only deeply humiliating
but consider a terrible attempt to for
presumption of innocence and I can give
if you're interested detail about the
fashion bug that inflation it is
strictly forbidden to present publicly
somebody as
completely when he is not much it does
this work created unanimity and the
certain confusion and center many people
protested vehemently you cannot find any
flesh before really that so a model for
the station you are at the same time
people saying it was a scaled out
because saw Scott was innocent actually
innocent than fight over there now
Thank others say it was has gone down
cause this guy must be presumed innocent
over whether there was who was in front
of this position but rapidly we
discovered that beyond the sin of the
world walking there was in fact and
Nancy much more romantic inferred people
the scene of the arrest itself in JFK
Airport of a very powerful powerful man
considered making to be the next
president of France and because of the
acquisition of the poor black guinean
housekeeper this scene contrary of the
Pacific was not seen by enemy we don't
have any image of that
plus it seems like they're giving the
imagination that the things grows us
atmosphere this kind of dimension and
finally we discovered it was not
possible for French people to escape a
difficult question would that and be
possible informed
of course the first Roy it was possible
but we stretch attitude towards powerful
person specifically in the political
field and bust our ass in France the
bottom of the substitute popular the
prosecutor is not independent many all
sorts that probably such an affair would
have been covered up I serve as a
direction of the intake or by there is a
judge in himself if you take me to base
in banks this question were difficult to
discuss when Sasuke was in the wicker
redesigning the first voice is planning
to speak about that where
the worst of things considering shocking
that a French it was so pretty by with
presumption of innocence and locked the
door with the alleged 15 perhaps we were
us add to be trusted it was a first
gender issue among friendly and when
some journals seem to justify the
policies of knowledge for an affair like
Java swag am speaking about massage the
diversity the quickie with of the best
the truth is an order professional from
dietary from the bus I was among those
who could not accept that that kind of
affirmation and be this kind of
protestation against the arrest season
of a powerful man because of the
complaint of a napski so I finished the
paper in bloom or the website entitled
la falda shown in VLC front st negates
the certain use of the argument of
presumption of innocence saying that our
politicians seem to know that if we
don't want this argument to be used to
justify may impunity we must accept a
new it
letters between prison
of innocence and presumption of veracity
unexplained and what is resolution of
veracity but before less goddess
presumption of innocence for the
measurement for some people the world
war was not only a very bad practice it
was the proof of an septum of the
reality of the American adversarial
system compared to the very good fresh
in kisii Toria 10 elisa and s Ministry
of Justice was one of the most combative
about that she said in french television
the images of bubble where of an
indiscreet people quality I am ugly we
don't have the same judicial system in
the American hustle system
prosecutor guess the only elements are
charged a man for the prosecution when
in France our shoes doesn't show
investigates the case was for the
prosecution and for the difference as
she act that the French and kisses of
your system perhaps takes more time but
is much more to put the protection for
for the mother rights of the persons and
here we got a very important or focusing
but the most patient is of no use with
some people some lawyers trying to
explain to French people who don't know
thing about the American designer system
worked was in fact the very fact that
this is them soon in this system is
American system is in fact very
protective of the presumption of users
and during the against the French people
they at least give us on and we were
this which White Hart establish a step
and we discovered all these aspects of
the incredible protection of presumption
of innocence with the judges consider
interview judge noted up an arbitrator
between prosecutor and
the difference the demoulas in to
process the unanimity of the 12 jun the
Commission to beyond all reasonable
doubt but you know at the beginning with
so patient so much back passionate
people with about forty seven percent of
fresh people believing all that was the
comparison group the voice of Israel's
there was not easy and for me it was
extraordinary to see this movement
against adversarial system when I
remember that in recent years we have ad
in front a very important very shortly
affair name l'affaire due to the name of
the place
loss of France Vanessa of NH pedophilia
and wait for of many children were not
among powerful people among poor enough
there were many people were falsely
accused and women remain four years in
prison before images and it was an
incredible story in France the bars the
gentle franchisees and in excellent
little booth penelon and analyzing the
auto case is there the New Salem witches
by footages entregado and the new cells
explain how the French in quito your
system with the secrecy of the
investigation with this judge belong in
the elaboration of what 20
one narrative because there is only one
choose you must give one manatee with no
discussion this they spin out this
system again a very difficult option for
any change if when you are in the
direction to cut go boom and as well
neither of the church offer even the two
children were huge and all that reveals
to be extremely problematic in the
concept of sexual crimes especially
children waves where emotion was so high
that many people want to have convicted
person before any packages
so our dinner we finished with this
discussion about presumption of
innocence I would say very rapidly that
what is important is when a occurs the
dismissal of charges in August because
of the lack of credibility of the
epicenter general the person who and
making politicians of jonathan's who
admit me and protesting against the
American
we did not give them any more and there
is two is exciting the first one is that
in a way the feminist point of view very
rapidly became dominant and i can tell
that i experienced myself that this
between the first week and it takes only
one legal or 10 10 days to add a
complete reversal and my policies for
example was what what lightly accepted i
was inviting that I would never like
that in France in addition radio every
so we cannot it is important
22 regstrate but for me my first
enemies in general this success because
it is significant of something important
what was revealed by the social affair
was not home this old country with his
thought massagem and determine what was
pretending what was repeat was a gap
between a changing society and the
behaviors
analysis of this little world of the
politicians and the joints and
specifically people generation
so another room another lesson is
freshly poured we're impressed very
impressed but by the capacity of the
American system to after and for the
prosecutor for Saracens after in such a
big important arrest of such an
important person took to come back to
change in front we never come back this
sastre it is one of the main reason of
emergency about
and false allegation and it the report
by seven plants was widely discussed and
considered in a way the modern of
pedagogy compared to French secrecy when
the judges never explained anything this
report was translating many before being
readied carefully from the beginning to
the end
and finally we accepted to receive we
see the lesson from America and there is
almost that many people in from Allah
ready to understand that there is no
contradiction between respecting the
rights of the containment of presumption
of veracity and respecting the rights
for the accused the question in a
general perspective is I think of French
people to acquire a new culture a new
culture especially before this he said
she said cases we don't have emotion to
tools for that for example we don't have
the mood culture for in the gravity of
Investigation all those other percussion
about
sincerity you cannot imagine how many
people entrusted you know in America
cannot lie
seriously III you want to give quitted
submitted to the computer the women who
who say they are engraved tumors other I
level of evidence of about the
responsibility
and now let's go to the second point
this the right is a non-political
opening green tea with
and the prism should what I caught the
vision of
what is presumption of diversity I i
enhance that be careful and I decided at
the right for the complainant not to be
considered reliable before it is proved
when I was done when I first proposed
his position of diversity I got other
system and at the same time a wide
approval and as many feminists who
criticized the attitude of our
politicians but us same times I have a
lot of critics from through many told me
this was a stupid consumer concept on
developing nonsense concept because I
bought you cannot say what you think and
the country and for them it was not
possible
to add at the same time presumption of
innocence and presumption of Paris so
let's take a few minutes to answer this
criticism at two levels available of the
French attitudes towards the voice of
the convenience and deliver of the
lobbies and he also what is frightening
for me is the change in society and the
gap between death and the consciousness
among a politician or individuals so
third moon the two scenes structure the
CC structure it is specially in the
twisted bandeau affair that's a question
of perception of veracity appeared
all its aspects and once again we had
this CC a structure the first one the
first scene which are concepts
concentrating all the attention all the
commentaries was as a moment when after
we came back to France source can appeal
for the first night on French television
on September in angels 30 million people
watch is a moment mr. de Botton foreman
winter country and as France and because
I know it was the first time yes Coast
Guard was speaking
since he was arrested it was beginning
of avenging what about this instant
forever just remember everybody
discovered that this moment asking
manage as an incredible demonstration of
power not only of our era of achieving
move you can add the moment you can add
the minute 20 minutes even a friend
prison donor welcome back sir
yes
earth looked and curing to broadcast
it'll be a sense or the question whether
they're all the other cells were
prepared what they see the movement of
the dance the movement of the eyes
everything was right there and when all
that was finished the journalist we was
a friend began to ask questions about
equally try asking it was a new expert
and the paralysis was gross
during this broadcast the Swiss can use
many times the report of silent ones he
had the report in the air and shoulder
import to them to the people to the
camera and I see it was the main Emeril
committee at one moment we said I would
mostly but consensual bathrooms in that
room it is not only to say that but the
prosecutor is said eventually you must
read the report I think that at that
moment source can be lost all the
advantages he could have
George's you know many people knew
precisely what was written in this
report they knew that there was nothing
like that so in at that moment before
all the first people Swiss Guard not the
issue disrespect for the full report for
the company convenient but for the truth
and people for 30 he acted like in the
old times in front of freshmen
he didn't understand our first history
was running since getting feisty and to
understand this incredible error made
you mustn't to unpack another see
another one Forrest brilliant and
expecting the scene which took place the
day after in this you see that what days
God shows can do not why we wasn't
interested did not understand is our
friend people have chained in the fence
about the present King of porosity Chris
envelope was inviting the day after
another television was also holy spot
affair providing
to explain our own affair and why should
complain of the past and begin why half
times and the other at the time was not
finished and it is incredible to do
everybody can look at that in the end
this machine is just in any old boys the
contrary of the one that took place the
day before Easter bernal surrounding
with the fortunate no yo Danny equipment
fraction German politicians they have a
discussion about them about what that an
intimate ease in this decision they
demonstrate what happened when a woman
is early recent and not considered
pacifist and below and be four years
they discussed and
they don't try to to give the good
answer they say it was very good in this
case he said she said it is difficult
the problem of the truth is difficult
but what is important is that banner was
able with year of birth and journalists
to not to treat only a case without any
context as for salmon as a method she
was the sociologist of his lawn tix she
speaking for women in front she speak
for the services of women who are raped
who don't bother plan don't complain and
she was able and he was very important
for the first people understand that
their attitude to work towards we
in this kind of affair is very different
from their attitude toward children and
the children we trust them when this
it's very often too much and it is a
problem but there is nothing like that
for the people and at the moment it was
for the first time personated to make
the distinction
and the day for the first time doing
this is intelligent say I don't know but
the item to speak about to stand back
okay and as usual he said that not here
but consensual between them and that all
what she she said was a lie die and that
what she has done was within hace esto
current news a force acquisition and
that can be put into signal in
complain injustice again for that and
what is interesting there for especially
40 yrs or for sociologists of uranium is
Sasuke seem to love to do and even his
lawyers single look not to me that a
very important change event in Frenchman
just one year before just on this
question of they know Tiesto can use
force acquisition what happens in the
best in the best when the woman a widow
a person accused sundered of the rain
forest and the charge where is this it
was possible Thornton
to return and to a future of the nosiest
remembers and eat and automatically the
woman was considered and treating a
sternum and each a woman who go to the
police or to suggestions unit so it was
a very important problem for French
feminist Association and there was the
case which very low one it was ten
blessing 10 years about only for the
woman who was accused by us supernovas
of that and and finally the Cougar will
be anyone home content from so and it
would be interesting to 12 a discussion
even about the detail of that because at
the arts of the chain was a very
interesting discussion about consent
because when you are accused of anything
done before stimulation most of the time
against this acquisition you said you
well do one for numerical methods but
bothering you under because and because
what make what is making the way it is
the lack of concept and something church
considered the woman who suggests she as
in red great she messes everything she
knows whatever and if she dies she knows
as it were so because of that it was
automatically that if any man or person
who
obtain the presumption of innocence and
the fact we're not true Putin after that
consider she was alone so I think it is
the church it's very important because
and women metal cyber knows that it was
four years in a mystery this question
that the fact the woman perhaps life at
consequences for all women and I was
myself very interesting about in
anything for for for personal reason
family for my family reason about the
impossibility for freshman for stronger
revolution to 19 and where took them to
see for Battlement locally sourced by
them because what was the reason
what was said that it was possible that
it was blood a man who Marcus who are
the father of my child so God not any
woman could do anything and my boat
grant Rama was in that case us the
domestic one and eating green can I
don't know what is attempting a child
for mesa boss and this bitch I was my
brother so other what is it for me
very romantic as know is four days after
saw son was arrested I had an
appointment with the board cousin just
to look together to the backpack the
papers of our family and just for us to
try to do something for the memory of
this grand mama so you can imagine how I
feel I affect my life not cause I'll do
it and decently need to be with the last
point the third of French culture
feminism sectionals the sous Califia
even fries discussion and didn't only
about the waivers act in front of an
alleged crime such as doing for sexual
assault for French people it was also an
affair to black us
yes our ordinary beer how between
sexuality in general and special
sexuality in the political sphere as far
as political leaders are concerned but
the condition for such an introspection
well not very as you knew it was your
burrows pregnant in the first day after
society was arresting when the first
people were accusing mmm an incredible
amount of reishi stereotypes through
from America to friendly and the modern
the most surprising shocking where the
fishing not about French name
but suspicion about French women in
seems to me at least paradoxical that
some people gave me or give us lessons
of feminism using one of the oldest
reflexed of machine look for the moon
try to find woman fault
and twisting us and we use finally like
two seats to CC structure the first
scene from the New York Times and The
New York Times end of this newspaper I'm
subscriber and paying all that on me and
paintings the New York Times website
published her room for the limit preps
winner entitled are French women or
tournament I put our fresh are
preventing thorns more forgiving of much
of sections the area whether it is
raisin integrated or sexual harassment
of coworkers or in this and then fair
stereotype
formation we were accused and do you
imagine the effect of French feminism
feminism flattering allegory for example
at Furman world where we wear such a
conflict or situation with our own
politicians to be accused of being in a
way responsible for the sexual assault
oh babe a famous french man i never met
at allegedly down on important algebra
when we look at the elegant contribution
of this room for debate we find some of
them especially come self not to play
this game of accusation stereotypes and
thank you
over fear but among them there was a
surprise and for me it was a shock to
discover that for example baby when done
and celebrating things and be so
judgmental name
use this opportunity to point her finger
of fresh feminism in general on another
woman historian in button without you
accuse and to enjoy a refreshing Ocean
of f'ing among other prepared the way
for made for sexual assault whisper
analysis of French culture of solution
civility and gamma Tauri in the
relationship between the sexes it is but
not my problem need to discuss about
announcing work I admire a lot but
mainly I it was not acceptable to read
them that to me at that moment that for
her who has always been a things
feminism was
performing in both involved to December
there's no argument that for this point
import was supposed to be culturally to
fetch advocating something you'd rush
innovate with your jeans because Muslims
could not learn that one else never one
word about listen and eat you know
something about our programs and
controversy funds about that now and a
very prominent wishes it is
two plays such a question can you
conceive everything is permitted I fed
myself to trash
and at the same time I was frustrated
that this discussion this acquisition
about submission and consent was not
booked or loomed interpretation and if
the source can add reputation it was not
a ton of fun on this question of out of
solution or signity or anything one else
of bananas in a brilliant way in burbs
full of American English I Jesus
business of energies of edith wharton so
to uncertainties to this form
and to meet with my bitter ends and
other see I decided to throw this as
seen on TV shame why not include
anything well for two reasons first
because we are certain sense of dignity
by certain sense to be proud of our set
we cannot accept to be treated in such a
way so I try and the reflex of jumping
and I want to take this team at to take
and the steel and we've done so I give
in other news paper glue mode he gave me
a one page and I invited
the maple to finish with the steamer
thinking these hypotheses not frenching
other horses thank you have been in many
in in at the same time I wanted to open
a move another important email about
solution and consents and I
I was very careful just one sentence
which have been largely discussed
assists and try to set it in English
feminism hypothesis is not bad it is not
only the way of thinking but away
the freshman Air Force acquaintance in
rights and a symmetrical pleasures of
sailors they want the absolute respect
of consent and the dishes surprise of
student kisses of course but
for me it was not only elongation
regimens authorities it was a way of
daily invest for years there was some
misunderstanding about seduction and
that we must absolutely distinguish
between solution as an art as a sort of
climate regime forces in a way of
approaching another person and the bajo
a way of interpreted in both sides in
person gift to you and try to not only
too bad the consent but to be sure she
consents this
solution has nothing to do with
submission as a kind of do for the kind
of violence for our sins and for that
the wood world is not solution but
panting and for the ultra the cold sense
of the enemy is not for my burger was
not understood John Scott answered they
are choosing your being and gauge what
his game and propose to the very prison
the presumption of the recipe I lie said
I at every for the same time everything
was empty but let me end this conference
with a different
music in fact I did not keep the
experience of my formula of my imagine
sent the inspectors of this polymer
allowed a significant measure of
seduction stolen disease where twin I
wanted default women i use dispersion
from women to wear fresh but one and the
main one was an American the French West
were conceived of red people recognize
ones shark ready for some a beautiful
song busybody
mmm
and the same is also a person who use
this song into dirty removing busy and
do you see if you can seriously pretend
that is stolen kisses as anything to do
with sexual harassment the other bedroom
was the one who gave I think the best
one of the best description i ever of
this with a symmetrical pleasure of
solution when solution is not it is an
American wife I
exploding
very much it's a marine and in medicine
and it was in his book on gay
relationships the Pharisee embrace and I
very much force is his book and we're
with the purity much more impressive
than indefinitely eternity in a dosage
very seductions something is less
appearance but between two men where you
can see two to look at to be looked at
extra all this place of a symmetrical
movement was
and then
I will not have a risk of collision it
is touring the country but a dingus
chance of speaking to you let me just
say that my prediction is and feminism
like literature is something we share
among devotion Ethan tsk affair would
just really more people that perceptual
free demo with it is somebody who are
well not any kind of integration from
the game of seduction it with your focus
the game of solution Thanks that's the
reason of medicine when should have very
well with the time for eons
for service but I peroxide it is normal
position and perhaps in landings